Ce qui est vraiment bien
dans les dîners de famille,
c''est qu'on s'emmerde pas.
C'est jamais chiant.
Faux !
Dans les dîners de famille, il y a toujours
le doyen ultra vieux, hein, un peu le chef.
Mais contrairement aux autres gens à table,
lui, on sait jamais si il s'amuse ou pas.
Cet homme est actuellement
en train de s'éclater.
Moi, j'aime bien
les grands-parents.
Ils sont gentils, mais ils ont
quand même l'art et la manière
de te faire bader en trois secondes,
avec ce genre de phrase :
Alors, pépé, quoi de neuf
depuis la dernière fois ?
Oh, tu sais, moi,
je vais mourir bientôt.
Ça marche !
D'ailleurs, c'est le seul
membre de la famille
à qui on parle
de manière très, très spéciale.
Alors, pépé, t'es content d'être là ?
Pourquoi personne me parle ?
D'ailleurs, moi, ma grand-mère,
elle a un délire.
Quand elle veut m'appeler
par mon prénom,
elle commence par faire le listing
de tous les prénoms masculins de la famille.
S'il te plaît, Denis, Thierry,
Jacky, Jean-Claude,
Stéphanie, Daniel, Norman,
tu peux me passer le sel, s'il te plaît ?
Merci.
Ma grand-mère,
elle adore bien me nourrir.
Elle me donne vraiment
beaucoup à manger,
quand j'ai faim,
mais aussi quand j'ai plus faim.
Tiens, Norman, prend
du gâteau un peu.
C'est gentil, Mamie,
mais j'ai plus faim, là.
Bon bah, prends un yaourt, alors. Tiens !
Écoute, Mamie, ça peut plus rentrer
dans ma bouche, là. Si je mange, je vomis.
Bon, OK. Mais prend au moins
un Quality Street.
Pfff !
Elle est trop gentille,
elle est trop gentille, ma mamie.
Dommage qu'elle soit morte.
Dans les dîners de famille,
souvent,
il y a les adultes
qui mangent entre eux
et à côté, il y a une petite table
dédiée aux enfants.
À cette table pour enfants,
il y a vraiment de tout type d'enfants,
de tous les âges,
et du coup, des fois,
je me demande à quoi
ressemble leur conversation.
Coco piti, coco piti.
Bon, écoute,
ce que tu dis, c'est ridicule.
Moi, je suis en sixième.
Tu sais à qui tu parles, là ?
Tu parles à un mec
qui a déjà fumé une clope.
Coco pipi dans pot.
Ah, tu fais dans le pot ? Ah pardon,
je t'ai mal jugé. Tiens, prends un Kiri.
Fais-toi un kif, c'est cadeau.
Moi, j'ai un max de thune,
cinq euros par semaine, je pèse !
Ce qui est vraiment super
dans les dîners de famille,
c'est que ça te donne l'occasion de revoir des membres
de ta famille que t'as pas vus depuis longtemps.
Mais des fois, ils oublient
que toi, depuis, t'as grandi.
Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Merci Tata, mais
j'ai 26 ans maintenant.
Qu'il est mignon ! Bon, allez, maintenant,
vas te laver les mains, on va manger.
Mais Tata !
>> Y a pas de mais !
À table, les oncles et les tantes
qui t'ont pas vu depuis longtemps,
ils aiment bien te poser 10000 questions,
de manière à juger ta vie actuelle.
Et c'est chiant, parce que des fois,
on dirait vraiment
que c'est la compétition de celui
qui aura le mieux réussi sa vie.
Alors, Christian, le travail ?
Ah ben moi,
toujours cadre.
Normalement je devrais passer
directeur marketing de la boîte, là.
Ça dépend des actionnaires,
mais on croise les doigts.
Attends, attends,
je reçois un mail.
Ouhou !
[applaudissements]
Et toi, Norman ?
Ben moi, je fais des vidéos,
dans ma chambre, pour Internet.
Bouh !
Évidemment, il y a un moment donné
où arrive la question :
Ben alors, t'as une petite copine ?
Je sais pas, moi, je n'arrive pas parler
de mes relations sentimentales avec ma famille.
Attends, c'est intime ! Je vais pas commencer
à leur raconter ma vie !
La petite Chloé, là, que j'ai vu
en photo, c'est ta petite copine ?
Chloé ? Ah mais non, mais Chloé,
c'est juste un plan cul !
Ouais, elle est venue justement
cette nuit chez moi.
On a niqué
comme des gros porcs.
À un moment donné,
elle a fait comme ça.
J'ai adoré ! Enfin, bref, ça reste un détail,
mais ça reste entre nous.
Mais sinon, on est juste potes, ouais.
Le pire, dans les dîners de famille,
je pense que c'est vraiment le beau-père,
c'est-à-dire le père de ta copine.
Il faut savoir que cet homme a une fille,
sa petite princesse, sa petite chérie depuis toujours,
à qui toi, tu fais l'amour
de manière ultra sauvage.
Ah ! Ah !
Et j'ai toujours peur qu'à
un moment donné du dîner,
il fasse allusion à ça,
à table, devant tout le monde.
Toute façon, les filles,
au début, elles sont timides,
mais après, une fois qu'elles arrivent au lit,
alors là, ça y va !
Oui, c'est clair, après [sifflement],
ça y va sec, hein, wouah !
Attends, tu parles de ma fille, là ?
Tu parles de ma fille ?
Ah non ! Ah non, non, non,
je parlais de—
Je parlais des autres filles.
Votre fille, je sais pas.
Ah ! Ah !  Ah ! Ah !
J'en sais rien.
Je pense pas, je pense pas.
À part quand elle fait comme ça :
Oh les mecs, comment
on parle à ma copine, là ?
C'est quoi ces manières ? Hein ?
Vous vous calmez, OK ?
Désolé, Monsieur.
Ah, j'aime mieux ça.
Tiens, ma chérie.
>> Mon bonnet !
Et ton bonnet ?
Ah, je lui ai donné.